when it comes to brexit conservative
prime ministers have
tended to face bigger political problems
from their own back benches
he might have an 80-seat majority but
boris johnson will not wish to alienate
brexiteers in his own party
by conceding too much to get a deal uh
one of those
is the former conservative leader sir
ian duncan smith pleased to say
he joins us now syrian very good to have
you on the programme this morning
um your same question to you as with all
guests at this morning
what chance do you think uh of us
actually getting a trade deal across the
line
well we'll have a trade deal uh i always
think this idea of no deal is a misnomer
we'll have a trade deal it'll be wto
world trade organization terms
uh what australia trades with etcetera
that's why it's referred to as an
australian deal so
we won't have a no deal we'll have a
deal it won't be the deal
that uh we we particularly would have
liked to struck with
uh europe and they say they would have
liked to struck with us as well
but as you were uh in your questioning
earlier on you pointed out
uh when the uk voted to leave the
european union
uh they did so to be a sovereign nation
controlling its own laws and its own
powers in its own
uh regional area its own waters um what
the european union is determined to do
is to stop that
and their proposals at the moment are
unacceptable to any sovereign nation and
by the way
um it was referred to as i think in the
last interview as being
or maybe the interview before with the
spanish minister as being a um
a similar deal to the uh nafta north
american free trade arrangement
it is not not one of them is expected
to accept the rulings of the other
courts in america
canada wouldn't accept that nor are they
going to have to sign up to all the same
regulations and stay with those they are
adjudicated if they're
using unfair competition that would be
given to an independent adjudicator
not not run by america not run by mexico
not run by canada
that's what the uk is asking for and of
course the european union point bank
refuses to grant it
it isn't part of the problem something
that you know people have been warning
about since you know actually the
referendum campaign
itself the idea that the european union
would give a better deal to the uk
than its own member states is for the
birds and that's
perhaps been one of the biggest sticking
points for us we want all the access
but we're not prepared to do what other
countries need to do
to get that access well to be fair we're
going to get access anyway trade is
going to carry on between the european
union and the uk
people uh talk as though you know the
day after the
of the 31st of december all trade will
cease with the uk
and europe not at all we export more to
countries now
a growing amount more uh than we do
which we don't have trade deals with
than we do with the european union the
60
of our overseas trade is with countries
like america where we don't have
a trade deal so let's you know we need
to put this into perspective
what we will have to do with trade with
them is trade rather like we do with
places like
america where you know countries
exporting who have to pay
tariffs and and correspondingly when
they import to us
we'd rather not have to pay those
tariffs and we'd rather the european
union have to pay tariffs
but if they were sensible and reasonable
we wouldn't have to but we will continue
to trade
this isn't going to be complete
armageddon people not trading at all and
bear in mind
our export trade to the european union
is around about 12 percent of our total
gdp the rest of it
is either abroad or in the uk sure but
but in the interest of
as broad a perspective and on these
issues as possible surely we also to
have to concede that if we leave on
wto terms there will be a hit to the
economy
there will be jobs lost the cost of you
know an average bag of shopping tesco's
estimates goes up by
three to five percent i mean it's not
the sunny the sunny
the sunny uplands that have been
described in the past a degree of
a degree of honesty about the economic
shock that we're going to experience
from january 1st onwards is surely
necessary as well
yes but i don't believe any of these
forecasts are correct every one of these
by the way produced by the bank of
england
or by the treasury has been
fundamentally out now for ages
and it all depends what you assume to be
the case of a uk
after it leaves the european union and
then trade separately
and all of their assumptions are that
other trade arrangements won't make any
great difference
yet if you look at trade deals done by
places like australia with the united
states they had a huge
impact on their economy made it grow
faster
so and i really do i'm skeptical because
there's a lot of scare mongering going
on the truth is
that the uk is uh the fourth largest
uh export destiny for the rest of the
world the fourth largest in the world uh
and
we export now uh dramatically huge
amounts but we also export
to many many countries our growing
exports in services by the way
uh go all over the world and the other
point about this deal which is not just
the way the european union's behaving
but they also refuse to have financial
services
in their deal which is our biggest
exporter so you can see straight away
it's a very one-way street
no country would accept that the other
country or the other group
would control the laws ruling the uh
their regulations
would be able to change their
regulations and make
the uk stay with those regulations
regardless even though we have no say in
it
and that would be adjudicated by the
european court of justice in what world
were those who voted for exit uh going
to be satisfied by that of course they
weren't
i think the thing about this by the way
which is really interesting is if people
didn't know why people voted to leave
the behavior of the european union right
now demonstrates exactly
why it's desperate to control everybody
it's desperate not to have competition
it's fearful therefore of the outside
world competing with it
and we know looking forward even under
eu figures they will only share about
four to
five percent of global growth over the
next 20 to 25 years so the markets
and the future is outside the european
union ian duncan smith thank you so much
for joining us in the program this
morning and
do have a merry christmas when it comes
and you very much